nos quitamos la mascarilla y llegando a
mostrar la más feliz de las sonrisas
después de casi dos años francia ha
levantado su requisito de tapabocas en
interiores para alivio de muchos que el
domingo vivieron sus últimas horas
enmascarados estamos vivos otra vez
me la voy a quitar y no me la vuelvo a
poner
era mediodía es genial por fin podemos
ver las caras de nuestros profesores
espero que no haya malas sorpresas
también para muchos niños pequeños es un
alivio no tener que llevar mascarilla en
la escuela
estaba cansado de llevarla porque era
más difícil oír a la profesora y estás
feliz de ver a la profesora sin
mascarilla eva nunca ha visto su futuro
sin tapabocas es la primera vez así que
es un gran momento va a hacer que todas
se sientan libres hemos esperado mucho
por esto
[Música]
sin embargo algunos creen que
levantamiento de esta restricción en la
mayoría de espacios es prematuro ya que
el virus todavía está circulando así que
es un cambio que puede no ser fácil para
todos
habrá que ayudarles a pasar por esto era
una retórica tranquilizadora que no les
haga sentirse culpables o preocupados y
se contagian o contagian a otros y los
niños no son los únicos que tienen que
adaptarse para muchos adultos el uso de
la mascarilla sigue siendo una medida de
seguridad esencial voy a mantenerla
durante un tiempo porque el coronavirus
sigue existiendo el sexo oral por ahora
es un poco pronto las mascarillas sigan
siendo obligatorias en transportes
públicos hospitales y residencias de
ancianos